[Applauso]
quante volte ci siamo domandati la
differenza sarà complicato e complesso
avrei capitato a me è capitato la
settimana scorsa quando le mie nipotine
ne hanno coinvolto a giocare con loro
con gli elastici hanno piazzato tutti
questi elastici sul tavoli hanno detto
adesso zia giochiamo e facciamo i
braccialetti facciamo i portachiavi
facciamogli scooby doo
li hanno chiamati così e sono messe lì a
insegnarmi come intrecciare per creare
cose cose nuove da un elastico è
un'unità semplice si trasformava c'era
un processo di trasformazione ed
evoluzione per il quale si creava un
nuovo oggetto
ecco questo è un po la base della
complessità in fondo da un'unità
semplice le interconnessioni che si
creano mettendo insieme oggetti semplici
fanno si che si crei qualcosa di più
complesso perché si crea
l'interdipendenza tra le parti ma c'è un
momento in cui complesso e complicato
diventano sinonimi è capitato
spessissimo di interpretare la parola
complesso come difficile per le mie
nipoti non è così è un processo di
trasformazione naturale e il loro gioco
quindi perché accade quando è che
iniziamo a confondere i due termini
probabilmente dobbiamo farci una prima
domanda non è forse la spinta del tempo
quella che ci spinge ad avere fretta
urgenza ad essere in qualche maniera
superficiale nei confronti delle cose
che abbiamo intorno a noi
quante volte che è cambiato di leggere
una notizia su facebook su internet di
leggere solo il titolo senza
approfondire ag la mano chi non ha mai
fatto
non ci credo noi sicuramente siamo
sempre spinti ad avere un'opinione
rapida sulle cose magari non abbiamo il
tempo di fermarci a pensare a
raccogliere i dati e raccogliere
informazioni per avere un pensiero non
dico complesso ma
completo ad avere un'idea più ragionata
sulle cose intorno a noi perché perché
poi accade che succedono delle cose un
po strane per esempio accade addirittura
che io mi candidi a sindaco di roma
nelle elezioni del 2015
non ve l'ho detto io lavoro nella
formazione ma ho anche questo passato
recente in politica scherzo ovviamente
era un esperimento nella story telling
politico ironico volevamo con uno slogan
che doveva essere evidentemente non
reale va dove ti porta libano non doveva
sembrare così verosimile e invece è
stato così le persone ci hanno creduto
l'analfabetismo funzionale l'abbiamo
provato sulla nostra pelle noi volevamo
provare semplicemente a dimostrare che
la narrazione politica di quel momento a
roma era talmente statica obsoleta da
essere poco attraente per qualunque
lettore di qualunque appartenenza e
invece abbiamo scatenato un piccolo
putiferio
abbiamo travalicato lo spazio digitale
in cui il nostro progetto era nato e
addirittura siamo andati oltre
sono finiti sulla stampa ci hanno
contattato le radio
ma la cosa più interessante mi hanno
votato ovviamente ho le prove
ho le prove abbiamo le testimonianze
dirette che il mio simbolo il cornetto è
stato scelto allora è ovvio che era un
esperimento fesr che doveva essere
evidentemente tale eppure non è stato
così facile perché era verosimile e
quindi le persone nonno scambiato per
reale hanno iniziato a dire ma non
parlare di antonia colasante è il giorno
di silenzio elettorale anche senza
accorgersi che appunto senza andare
oltre il titolo della notizia che faceva
chiaramente capire che non ero un
candidato vero perché era accusato
questo perché c'è tutta questa urgenza
questa tendenza a correre verso un
successo che si può raggiungere soltanto
in un'escalation continua per il quale
noi dobbiamo affrettarci ed è sempre un
passo
davanti a noi le aziende e manager che
incontro quotidianamente lavorando nella
formazione mi restituiscono questo
aspetto questa loro incapacità di
fermarsi perché intravedono sempre il
successo come qualcosa che si deve
raggiungere ma si deve raggiungere
facile deve essere una cosa a portata di
mano
mica mi vorrei far fare qualcosa di
complicato addirittura complesso no qual
è la tendenza cercare la scorciatoia non
vedete forse in giro tutte le volte 10
strategie per raggiungere il successo il
10 trucchi che non avevi mai sono tutte
ricette che pretendono di restituire
contenuti elaborati da qualcun altro e
che andiamo a cliccare per scoprire
magari chissà quale verità nascosta che
non immaginavamo di conoscere che ci
svelerà un segreto che non conosciamo
ma non è così evidentemente perché
perché poi alla fine tutte le imprese
che io incontro pretendono di avere il
cartellino di impresa innovativa noi
siamo innovativi noi vogliamo fare la
digital trasformation spesso la mia
battuta re ma avete mai iniziato a fare
la mind trasformation iniziare a
cambiare ottica con cui vedete costruite
l'organizzazione che avete intorno le
persone che avete attorno perché
evidentemente l'innovazione si può
vedere una caratteristica di complessità
e io vedo ancora tante aziende che sono
basate su aspetti pesantemente
burocratici il tutto l'anno tranne che
qualcosa che ha a che fare con la
complessità sono imprese innovative per
etichetta e non per contenuto faticano a
immaginarsi in trasformazione
perché trasformazione è complesso e
impegnativo richiede tempo
il tempo è una parola che ci tornerà
oggi utile come riflessione perché vuol
dire superare l'inerzia del pensiero
vuol dire che io sulle cose devo avere
il tempo di
dedicare uno spazio mentale per
comprenderle per assorbirle e per
assimilarle e invece normalmente quando
facciamo formazione ci troviamo spesso
in aula delle persone che non hanno
questa attitudine latitude che invece
leggo più spesso è quella di tutela
docente
quindi adesso mi rovescerà une contenuto
di conoscenza che andrà magicamente a
riempire gli spazi del mio cervello che
attualmente sono vuoti e quindi ti prego
di fare anche ordine non mi mettere in
disordine i neuroni per cortesia
allora forse non è così
la ricerca delle soluzioni e poi
confezionare il modello della formazione
fast food quello in cui io sono il
distributore di conoscenza e loro quelli
che mettono il gettone forse non
funziona forse a qualche momento diciamo
di fallacia interna che evidentemente lo
rende povero altro che resilienza le
aziende che continuano a parlare di no
di trasformazione e di gestione del
cambiamento
siamo lontani se questo è il modello con
cui le persone si confrontano quello
sviluppo evolutivo nella loro formazione
del loro apprendimento non si dedica
tempo ad assorbire la conoscenza il
tempo invece è qualcosa che ci
schiavizza qualcosa che ci mette in
quella urgenza che dicevo prima
un tempo che ci schiaccia e che ci
obbliga a essere in ritardo continuo in
questa corsa perenne dove bisogna fare
presto bisogna essere multitasking
bisogna fare tante cose insieme
bisogna essere in grado di gestire molti
molti livelli e questo è un punto di
forza viene visto come un elemento di
valore ma la domanda che spesso faccio a
alle persone che mi candidi incontrare e
che hanno questo sistema esattamente tu
il tempo che risparmi ma dove lo metti
che ci fai
ne sei consapevole che spesso ti sei
messo dentro un circolo vizioso in cui
continui a risparmiare tempo in questo
tempo non lo si mai perché forse la
domanda sulla priorità
qual è la priorità che tu sai qual è il
valore nel tempo che hai risparmiato
magari lavorando di fretta non lo usi
per lavorare ancora più in fretta se
sicuro che la priorità è proprio quella
è quella che vuoi spendere e quello è il
tempo che vuoi dedicarti nella nella se
vedete cioè quel grafico che è una
citazione del film 32 dicembre di
luciano de crescenzo in quel film
bruciate le scienze dice che il tempo
non va allungato non bisogna continuare
a inserire azioni consecutive anche
magari parallele pensando che si possa
comprimere il tempo il digitale con
prime tante cose si comprimono le
relazioni le distanze ma il tempo è
l'unica cosa che non si può comprimere
allora forse inutile ragionare inserendo
ulteriori elementi e cercando di
allungare il tempo il tempo va allargato
va allargato nell'area delle emozioni va
allargato nella capacità di creare nuovi
significati nuovo senso 9 apprendimenti
e trasformandosi nel proprio processo
evolutivo come manager come
professionisti nel proprio sviluppo
professionale ma non sono evidentemente
questo questa esperienza di paradosso
rispetto alla capacità di gestire il
tempo e di voler migliorare se stessi mi
è diventata ancora più evidente da
quando lavoro nella facilitazione quindi
non solo faccio formazione ma facciamo
gruppi di facilitazione a rendere non è
sembrato vero quando abbiamo detto che
facevamo facilitazione finalmente una
cosa facile quindi sarà veloce e rapida
e sarà quella famosa ricetta che
chiedevano prima e invece questo
pregiudizio è stato è stato così
evidentemente fallace per loro perché
forse la parola non è stata quella
giusta forse non bisognava dire
fascinazione bisognava rimandare più al
tema della complessità perché nella
fascinazione il fascio datore non fa
altro che aiutare il gruppo che ha
davanti a ragionare su un tema ma farlo
è far emergere i contenuti le idee le
soluzioni da quel gruppo non è portatore
di un contenuto non è portatore di una
conoscenza del portatore di una
metodologia e quindi la verità che
facilitare non è semplice ma è molto
complesso non è veloce come spesso ci
chiedono nelle aziende
anzi in particolare la metodologia delle
voci display è una di quelle che più di
tutte sconvolge il mondo delle aziende
che si aspettano qualcosa di
entertainment
va bene quindi se tu lavori con i lego
adesso vieni e far giocare i nostri
manager con i lego questi magari
scaricano un po di conflitti che
diventano più coesi team building queste
cose così la metodologia nome doveva
molto complessa non è affatto facile
perché perché noi chiediamo alle persone
di ragionare attraverso quelli che sono
i mattoncini creando nuova conoscenza il
mattoncino non è altro che un artefatto
cognitivo vuol dire che noi chiediamo
alle persone
basandoci sulla teoria delle
neuroscienze nelle quali la connessione
mano cervello rende potente mattoncino
perché la manualità il fatto di entrare
in contatto con un oggetto fa sì che la
persona possa accedere a nuova
conoscenza possa accedere a sui
contenuti che non sono di utilizzo
quotidiano
ma che lui sa che sono portatori le
persone e quindi noi chiediamo alle
persone
costruisci la tua migliore competenza
costruisci la creatività con i
mattoncini e come si fa
eppure la capacità di costruire metafora
è qualcosa che ci viene assolutamente
naturale è molto più difficile da
raccontare
voce che vi assicuro vedere le persone
giocare certo è l'unica come attività ma
è molto complessa le storie che ne
vengono fuori sono molto articolate sono
sempre costrutti nuovi che le persone
riescono a far emergere proprio perché
la metodologia ludica supera le
resistenze cognitive e ci consente che
accederà un bagaglio maggiore di
informazioni di know how di tutti e si
creano veramente contenuti interessanti
per le aziende che riescono a entrare
nell'ottica di sperimentarsi purtroppo
non sempre accade perché le persone
anche davanti a una metodologia che di
fatto dovrebbe essere accattivante e che
quindi dovrebbe facilitare la messa in
gioco di se stessi
ci sono le persone che rimangono sul
bordo mi è capitato qualche settimana fa
di avere delle persone che mi hanno in
un corso in cui facevamo lavoravano
sulla cultura organizzativa dell'errore
non va bene ci va bene e lavorare
sull'errore interessanti abbiamo
lavorato bene fino a quando abbiamo
lavorato sugli errori degli altri però
attenzione perché lei non si può parlare
perché diventa un po troppo complicato
noi vogliamo lavorare sugli errori su
come aiutare gli altri hanno sbagliato
noi mica sbagliamo mai quindi mattoncini
sono i dati pensiero sono irritati
pensiero che vuol dire vuol dire che
sono esattamente come gli elastici delle
mie nipotine sono elementi che impilati
ci consentono che accederà una nuova
conoscenza un contenuto complesso una
storia ne facciamo creazione di storie e
in questo story telling che viene creato
ognuno ogni persona che partecipa deve
sentirsi responsabile del proprio
contenuto deve sentirsi in grado di
diventare protagonista perché il
facilitatore è un regista che mette
tutti i partecipanti in grado di
diventare attori protagonisti del
proprio processo evolutivo e della
propria crescita professionale ma ognuno
poi deve metterci il proprio pezzo di
responsabilità per credere in quello che
sta facendo
per costruire proprio story telling per
farvi quel work in progress un elemento
per apprezzare la complessità piazza
[Applauso]